you look
great you're you're the first person
I've interviewed it's in all white I've
worn all white for over seven years oh I
love it it's all I own you look great
thank you you can't you don't see many
people wearing all white I do it
sometimes I noticed that yeah no you
look great um so how many times have you
seen the Grateful Dead 101 times 101 yes
this this was what age were you doing it
15 was my first show uh it was at Alpine
Valley
1984 and I think it's been six countes
my brother bought me a ticket
to for my birthday to uh ACDC and so a
couple years later there was all these
advertisements on the radio for Grateful
Dead and I just thought it was a heavy
metal band and so I went to the show
with a 15-year-old friend took a bus out
there and it was just like this parking
lot scene with hippies and people
selling peanut butter and honey banana
sandwiches and like just bands in the
parking lot and just this scene of like
love and hippies and you just felt this
energy that you just but you was this
1984 and then um at that show we
actually we B for the bus tickets and
then when we took this bus out with a
bunch of other people um you're supposed
to change the bus
ticket with the driver for the ticket
into the show so the show's about to
start we get there 5 hours early we're
Meandering through the line Alpine
Valley this massive venue and did you
look like a dead head then Wisconsin I
look like a dead head um no I didn't
know what a dead head was I would had uh
normal hair I mean I was 15 so it was uh
eight oh so so you you became a dead
head after this became a dead head after
that oh I see but there's an interesting
scenario when we got to the front Gates
we didn't have we had these tickets that
were bus tickets I mean we were so naive
and green and they looked at us like we
were insane and there's like 10,000
people behind us and we they took pity
on us though and they basically they
walked us in backstage they sat us in
front and it was just this music that
made you want to dance and um a guy next
to me had some mushrooms we took a
couple it wasn't a very intense trip but
it was just this amazing place and then
after that I fell in love with the scene
of the love and the music and that's a
whole another story and the Greatful
that had a 600 song repertoire so they
would do a spring summer winter all tour
you could go see 15 shows you might see
four songs repeated they had two
drummers and they'd always have a drum
solo in the middle so it was never the
same show and then like the next year
they came
back for three days I went to all three
days and then we also followed him to
Chicago and then 17 when I was 18 so 84
85 86
87 88 and then in 89 and by then I
probably had already saw 20 shows I went
to Canada to see them one time New York
City and uh but then I just took off
with them I was met this girl in high
school we dated for four years we were
going to get
married and I the white picket fence and
everything I had a full-time job I
bought a brand new car and I was just
like I'll do this with you but I have to
just go see the dead come with me and so
she said no and I left and I went on
tour with the grateful Dad and um after
that it was 8990 91 92 until
92 91 and '92 I really wasn't on tour
and in like 1990 I really ceased with
all LSD sales because the fear of going
back to prison but you eventually turned
into a dead head looked like looked the
part I did I did look the part probably
by I mean in school you there was like
the jocks and the the greasers you had
hair down your back the Derp ball so
then I that's what we called them and
but I became I was a jock when I went in
in and I was Varsity wrestler I played a
little football but then I became a um a
derpal so to speak but I never I had
long hair but not like once I went on
tour but there was a safety first on
tour too like selling drugs and there
was always this safety first in my whole
life of selling drugs even when like in
high school we grew pot my friends all
grew pot and I remember the first time I
came home with a quarter pound which was
right around the time of that first Dead
show and I um my mom said something like
it's you stink like a skunk and so right
away the fear and then this is the
dichotomy of it because you're doing
something that your parents don't want
you to do it's illegal but it's not like
I was you know waking up smoking pot
stealing money to get it it was it was
more of a recreational thing and I
really wasn't harming anyone but it was
highly freaking illegal like people
today don't understand of what we went
through and today you can just get
anywhere but like even on dead tour when
we were driving through like the state
of
Texas everybody put everything away it
was hidden every no tie eyes your hair
was back and like for the next 15 hours
because in Texas in the 80s if you got
pulled over with a couple joints you
were going to prison I mean it was a
felony so after that happened with my
mother I um I started hiding it outside
and I anytime anybody wanted to buy it I
would there would be places we lived
right by a park and would go dig it up
but I'd never have been caught with
drugs in my life ever there was one time
at a uh Grateful Dead Show 8990 New
Year's in San in Oakland or San
Francisco whever they did the New Year's
Eve show and um I was walking in my
hotel room was a Motel 6 and it was
Notorious with the Oakland Police
supposedly they owned it and I had about
34 of an ounce on me with about
$700 and they just grabbed me like this
and threw me in the car
and they said we're going to bust you
unless you tell on your friends they
didn't know anything who I was or
whatever it was New Year's Eve there was
10,000 hippies everywhere and they
grabbed the ounce they said it was an
ounce it was 3/4 of an ounce anyway I
spent the next six days in
jail arraignment because it was during
the weekend so like they didn't have it
on the Friday and then it was whenever
the New Year's fell and it was just this
Fiasco my first taste of jail but when I
went in front of the judge the
arraignment judge he threw it out they
even gave me all my money back the exact
bills they had saved it in evidence
because the cops like this is over an
ounce and if it's over an ounce it's a
felony so it's just so I guess in that
sense they caught me but they just
essentially there was no reason for them
to grab me so that was a bad experience
but um the safety first was the the the
Paramount thing of my whole life selling
heroin in prison or selling the
marijuana um and in prison I sold heroin
just to support my marijuana habit and
that's just something that we could get
into that if you want to but that is you
went to prison for drugs selling LSD yes
I had nine counts of interstate commerce
for LSD and nine counts of money
laundering and the way the statute is
written for the Mund money laundry and I
think it's 1856 but it's a statute about
that thick so money laundering is
besides what you think of like we're
going to hide all the money in gold or
we're going to buy real EST state if I
send you money from an illegal
transaction and say I use the mail or I
wire it to you any sort of transferring
of money that falls under the money
laundering statute so it's a very broad
application of the law and then um when
they arrested me they already had an 18c
count Federal indictment that they had
convened a grand jury for nine months
before and then they were following me
around the country trying to catch me
with
LSD um because then they know they've
got you and then the the whole game was
if they get you they can get you to tell
and then they get the bigger fish and
the thing is with
LSD for us like LSD was a Sacrament it
was
a it was a spiritual experience it was
something that I never abused I never
knew anyone who abused it if you take
like a quartz crystal it looks like a
gram gr like a gram of LSD looks like
this like a quartz crystal would look
like same size as a gram of cocaine but
it's 10,000 hits and there's very few
people in the world that have ever seen
Crystal LSD I mean these these people we
we had a conspiracy to want to bring
about radical social change and that's
really when you think of LSD Albert
Hoffman um discovered it in
[Music]
1938 and then he first took it in April
19th of 1943
and then MK Ultra the CIA got a hold of
it in the 1950s they did a lot of
studies with alcoholism uh Bill Wilson
the founder of um Alcoholics Anonymous
did a lot of research with it with the
psychologist Cohen here at the lava but
they were doing that all over the
country but what they realized was is
that it kind of made people the
cultural imprinting the neural
imprinting that we have as a culture to
live a certain way the the farming
system Society the work like it sort of
stripped that all
away and it didn't make
you lazy or like you know you're
addicted to heroin or fentanyl or
something like that but it was
more you just really saw the world for
what it was and um so that's sort of
like some of the history of where LSD
came from but when I was younger I was
always afraid that LSD was going to make
me insane and so I did mushrooms a
couple times and then when I would go to
the
shows and I was a small time I was a
small time guy I never had more than six
or $7,000 ever in my life of of selling
drugs and I if I could get two or three
th000 in between shows that would get me
to a whole summer tour I mean this was
the 80s if you're with two or three guys
we each got a couple Grand it would get
you to the next show and then like at
the shows you could always sell grilled
cheese and beer if you if you went like
down to like three or 400 bucks and then
in two shows you'd have a couple
thousand doll and then the really good
people that were making the LSD if they
thought you were addicted to alcohol or
you did heroin or cocaine ever you would
not be able to buy LSD from them and
there's very few labs in the history of
LSD that have ever been busted I mean
it's a very
clandestine thing you cannot make it in
a bathtub you need about30 $40,000 worth
of glass wear maybe 5 days days and
you'll end up with four or five million
hits but these people did not drive
expensive cars they didn't have bling
bling they really wanted to bring about
radical social change and so uh I don't
know if you've ever heard of bear
Augustus sley III he was the original
soundman for the dead he came up with
the steel your face which is that skull
with the lightning 13-point lightning
bolt um he made exceptionally good LSD
um the purple barrels Oley he died about
10 years ago but essentially like the
Electric Kool-Aid Acid Test with Ken
kesy he was part of the MK Ultra
unbeknownst to him and then one day he
stole 500 hits out of the cabinet and
then he went on with the Mary pranksters
the bus further Fu T Hur and then they
took it all around the country that bus
is actually in the Smithsonian today in
New York City I don't know if you know
the history of all that you probably do
though because you're from California no
I don't I'm from Chicago oh you from
Chicago that's right anyway well you're
in Cali Cali in California I'm Sor you
were you were doing this for how long
selling LSD and touring with the dead
so that okay so 80
884 I had taken mushrooms and I smoked
marijuana but then in 85 I that's when I
bought my first sheet of LSD now on
occasion mushrooms would come into town
in Milwaukee and maybe I'd get a quarter
pound and you'd make 6 800 bucks off of
it um but the first sheet of LSD that I
ever bought was the very next year I was
16 I drove and so that was
1985 and I would buy a sheet one sheet
of LSD from someone that I didn't really
know I never sold drugs at a parking lot
in the Grateful Dead never ever that was
like the cardinal sin you would never do
that you might meet someone and plan to
meet him in two or three weeks in a city
but never ever did I taint the scene of
Grateful Dead with with that but I did
score and so I took that sheet back to
high school and I think I sold each hit
for like eight or N9 but like two people
bought the whole thing so for what I
paid $30 for I probably got back six or
700 bucks now I did that four or five
times over the next 84 85 86 87
88 and then maybe by 88 I'd find someone
I'd buy like eight sheets which is 800
hits
and then but I never was like selling
single hits like people would just say
I'll give you a th bucks when I came
back to Milwaukee so like that would be
240 to a th000 but when I went when I
would told you about the girl we were
going to get
married and then I went to on tour so
that was the fall of 1989 and I still
had not taken LSD at this point I get to
the first LSD trip um and so I went on
it it started in Brendan bird and it was
October 13 14 15 16 I believe 17 there
were four or five shows and it happened
to fall on October 15th
1989 which was the year anniversary of
my father dying died right in my arms
the year before but I didn't remember
that and because my friends they grew
really good marijuana
um I brought a pound with me on tour and
then I met some people who I'm still
friends with today who knew some people
that they were with and because I had
this really good um marijuana they like
that was my in and they just sort of
looked through my soul and then I got
the connection to uh we'll just say
rainbow but they were chemists and they
loved the weed um so I'm at the show do
you want me to tell you about the first
time sure and uh W with this beautiful F
woman and um I decided okay I've taken
mushrooms I don't think LSD is going to
make me go crazy I've done this
research looked at it and it's like I
want to try it one time you know the
fear of because of the stuff that the
culture told you over the years
about the you're going to jump out of
window and all the BS and so we were in
the show before it started way early and
we we we she gave me one and she took
one and then we're like you know 10
minutes later she gave me one she took
one I can't believe I'm saying this on
camera anyway she had a whole sheet and
she's friends with the people that I met
and just we kind of became this one
little sub family of the big family and
uh and so I don't know maybe there is
pretty soon there's like 20 hits off
this sheet she's took eight or nine and
10 and you know and then all of a sudden
um the lights were just getting a little
weird and then but it was just beautiful
trip so like we saw the show but we
realized like cuz we kept you know say
she had never taken it either maybe once
before she did and uh it was a beautiful
trip the lights kind of kept getting
dimmer and slower and um but what LSD
does is it breaks you down to the moment
to um the vibrations and the colors you
basically you see sounds you hear colors
and then today within the last 25 5
years if you talk to like a nano
scientist and they can actually
everything is a wave and everything has
a color and they can look at it with
cameras and then they can also listen to
like a leaf and and what it what it
emits and so it sort of just brings you
down to a place that
is I mean I can't explain it with words
but it's not something that we weren't
drunk we weren't High it wasn't like it
was very well thought out because the
the 15th oh yeah the 15th was the third
show so I had met them the second I came
to the parking lot so this is like the
third day we're hanging out and um then
I realized this was a year ago to the
day that my dad died and I had a moment
and um I'll tell you about my parents my
parents uh I was born in Chicago my
parents met a Playboy my mom posed for
centerfold in the 1960s Pompeo posar
just hounded the crap out of her and she
finally relented my dad collected
money um they told me about parties at
like the Mansion on State Parkway and
but during that trip and I want to share
this memory with you when I was 5 years
old my dad took me to a Chicago
Blackhawks game at the Chicago Stadium
it was in October of 74 so I was like
five and a half and they won 10 to four
and I remember when they scored the
first goal and I was standing standing
on the ground and the whole stadium
Shook and it was like there was an
earthquake and I just remember grabbing
onto his legs and then he picked me up
above the crowd and then the sound like
that is imbued in my spirit like the the
memory of that game and then I remember
my brother took me to a game down there
when Jordan was playing or someone but
it was after they wrecked they wrecked
it and it's gone but you have you ever
been there when it was in Chicago
Stadium many times it was amazing so um
but that was my first LSD trip and then
after that is when I met the people and
they were
very careful about who they sold it to
and the safety first and then basically
training me and then like the way that
we transferred the money was a very
sophisticated way and we would send the
LSD
overnight
um you would wire the money through
Western Union and you
would you would use use a fictitious
name and a physical description and like
a code question now you can't do that
anymore I'm not giving away any secrets
for anybody you you it's got to be an ID
and so even back then there were times
where I remember one time at the San
Francisco Jerry Garcia shows there was a
Western Union open till like 2: a.m. and
I went in there and I filled out three
pieces of paper I'd sent I think a,
1,500 hits was roughly 55 4,500 bucks
it's three different slips of paper
three different same physical
description and then three different
test questions and like I got the money
and then the people that I always sent
the LSD to like whenever I did the
overnight envelope like I never touched
anything with my hands I wrote with my
left hand like there was no trace of
anything and like so and then they would
always they they told me like if you if
any heat ever comes
down you know like and you had to throw
something away like Safety First don't
worry about it and they would have
fronted me as much as I wanted but I I
never thought really big like that but I
always had this incredible fear of going
to prison and so there was this constant
juxtaposition of what do I believe in
but am I willing to risk my freedom for
it and like on a dead tour literally if
you had four or 5,000 you were Rich
because you could maintain 3 or 4,000
just by selling some grilled cheese
you're not really you got a Coleman
stove and you go to the local grocery
store and you're just getting to the
next show but the the the Grateful Dead
I mean for lack of a better word it was
like a church and like when when I was
there it it everything stopped like you
were in the moment it was this beautiful
scene there was very little drama um it
was just a really kind and gentle place
and I was I was kind of a troubled kid
growing up so I didn't you know I didn't
really know which end is up I still
probably don't but I'm a little I know a
little bit more than what I did and um
it was something that I loved to do but
deep down in my heart I knew that LSD
was not bad I knew it was illegal and
the government looked at it that way and
um the uh the penalties for it were
absolutely unbelievable I mean people
the drug laws the way that they happened
in the80s were so intense and so
barbaric I mean people were getting 30
40 years for growing marijuana LSD I had
a level 34 in the sentencing guidelines
with the two twoo hment enhancement for
leader organizer two-o enhancement for
continuing career criminal and then one
other twoo enhancement but after trial
they he did away with the
three and then I had so I had level 34
and I think it goes up to 40 or 42 and
then he said 151 months he gave me the
bottom of the guidelines which right
away I knew it was 12 years 7 months I
jump for joy how did you get caught and
so so I got caught I was guilty I did
what they said I did but I wasn't really
caught so I don't know if you know how
the justice system works but a lot of
times people get arrested and they might
be in possession of something and so
then they may convene a grand jury or
you might plead guilty and the one of
the things that saved me in jail was the
fact that I took my case to trial which
I didn't understand the ramifications of
that but it garnered respect and every
prison I went to CU basically 95 is% of
the people in federal prison under the
drug laws plead guilty because if you
don't you've got a 99% chance of losing
and so they how did I get caught so they
convened a grand
jury I got indied but I didn't know and
they started following me around the
country and then I was going to work for
my brother to declared that I wasn't
going to sell drugs he had a big
landscaping company he's like work with
me for a year and I'll give you half and
I was getting ready to go to work and I
thought um Jesse was there to pick me up
and it was the um the
DEA and they they said are you Joel
Blazer I said yes they threw me down to
the ground guns drawn trigger [__]
there's two guys out front with shotguns
two guys in
back and um and he had the indictment
and he threw it in my lap he's like he's
like you're facing 40 years he's like
it's 20 years to count he's like it's at
least 40 years they took me to jail I um
I had to do an arrangment this whole
ordeal I had to go through the whole
federal prison system before I got back
to Kentucky and then um I was bailed out
but they had evidence from a gentleman
it's the only person I don't Name by
name in the
book as a one of my customers I'll just
say on the east
coast and he and I had did business
maybe a dozen times and I sent them
maybe 10 12,000 he'd buy a thousand hits
at a time and um when they arrested him
remember the scenario I told you about
the wiring and the the ficti and the
fake all that he his friend got I sent
him a thousand hits he sold his friend
25 hits and that guy got in trouble and
then he told on Marty and it all came
out at trial but Marty the sheriff's
just went to Marty's house just to say
this guy said you sold us the LSD and
um he broke down right on the front
steps and then he told the
sheriffs the the story about how he gets
this overnighted to him and then he
burns the envelope and he goes to the
Western Union and then they can't they
said we're going to have you committed
for for uh surveillance or something
because they thought he had he was like
mentally there was something wrong with
them but the DEA got wind of it and they
came to the mental hospital cuz they're
he there was nothing wrong with them and
they and he told that to the DEA and
then the DEA said um you just admitted
to a federal crime you're going to get
15 years unless you help us get him so
they he made a lot of calls and they the
only but anytime I talked on the phone I
would just say they're like look we're
going to the show on the 27th I want to
get 21st row seats cuz the at that time
in the 80s Greatful dad was the number
one grossing band if you look at the
records 8788 89 90 30 40 50 million they
were a top grossing act and so it wasn't
like I was making millions of phone
calls but they had a couple phone calls
where he was asking for front row
Grateful Dead tickets 10 or 12 never
ever I mentioned a drugs I mean my
lawyer was amazing Gatewood galberth it
was like a Perry Mason situation but the
jury found me guilty and then I want to
go back to my dad and the honor so I got
bailed out I don't care who you are when
you're facing 40 years you're going it's
going to test your [__] metal excuse
my language but when whoever you are
like 40 years is a tough hallway I was
23 years old you know and
um what and my family they loved me but
they're like look you have to cooperate
you've got to do something you can't go
to prison
and I just remember one day shaving and
um I looked at myself in the
mirror and anybody that says they're not
going to consider it as a liar but
nothing was said at all when I was
arrested no statements were made but
when I was shaven I'm like I'm not I
cannot be a rat because of me I mean the
the people that I dealt with were
beautiful but they would have never
killed me there would have been no
threat they probably would have paid me
money if they could have done an actual
LSD lab bust but I'm like I cannot do
that I am not that person so I said I'm
going to try to win this
trial and uh I went to trial and I just
knew it was sort of a write of Passage
and I expected to get 20 years but I
remember my dad honor I remember in high
school sometimes everybody would get in
trouble something would happen and then
everybody would tell on themselves and I
wouldn't and then the principal would
get mad but I wouldn't get suspended
they'd send me home and my dad I didn't
lie but he was always about like stand
up for yourself and honor and never tell
like that was the thing he fought in the
War and he just he was a very honorable
man and I saw him do things that were
along those lines and so I don't know if
that affected me I mean obviously it in
prison I did some Shenanigans which was
not cool but since getting out
20 6 years ago I've done there I've been
you know I'm a square I pay taxes I do
what I do and so that that's cool but I
could not do what he did to me but I was
[__] scared man it's prison like you
all the stuff that you think happen can
happen what what prison were you in so I
started out in
[Music]
um Sandstone Minnesota which was a low
and I had 151 months and um I mean how
much do you want me to get into it well
I mean you ended up in Maran I ended up
in Maran tell me about Maran um
Marian is
a there's a story behind Maran that I
learned in the first prison but
essentially Maran opened after Alcatraz
closed United States Penitentiary
Maran um in 63 and so the most of the
prison had normal movement but it was
still the highest security prison and
then there was one unit called
hunit that was 23-hour lockdown and that
was a model that was a super max section
of a prison which no other prison in the
world had but essentially there were
Clayton
Fontaine and Tommy Silverstein were in
that prison and on the same day and in
that part of the prison hun it when you
came out of your cell you had to be
handcuffed and Shackled and two guards
were next to you one of them broke away
to another cell they unlocked his cuffs
and he killed the guard and horribly
maimed two others and then at the
simultaneously the same time Clayton
Fontaine killed a guard that was in
80 one or two and then after that
happened they declared Maran they made
the whole entire prison of Maran the
supermax prison that was known up until
maybe 2005 so the whole entire prison
was locked down single cells you can
never be next to a guard and left your
handcuffed behind your back Shackled and
there's three of them so that was what
they called the Maran model and that was
the new supermax ever the whole entire
prison so there were riots in
Talladega over the crack law now while I
was in
prison Clinton made all these uncredible
laws you know this whole Aura of the you
know the drugs and lock them up and
every you know everybody's getting 10 20
years
[Music]
um they changed the LSD was 10,000 to1
sentencing and they changed the LSD
law because they were weighing the
carrier medium so a gram which is 10,000
hits they would weigh one sheet which
might weigh three grams or an sugar cube
so there was this disparity and then
with the l& m methampetamine law and the
marijuana law if you had 50 cuting of
marijuana right and say they came in and
found the 50 cuting they would say each
cutting
was
um like an ounce but if you had 51
cuting this is the federal law at the
time if you had 51 cuting just one more
they would count each one as a kilogram
which is two pounds so now that's 100
pound so the sentencing commission
changed all three of those
interpretations as a result of every all
this pressure but those all
predominantly affected white males
mostly over 90% on each of them and the
L&M methamphetamine law is like when you
would get that stuff the edrin for
your what people were doing like they
were buying those pills and crushing
them and they were selling that as meth
but it really wasn't but when they would
test it it was so close the feds didn't
say well it's not real meth so they that
was that was how they changed that and
then the crack law came up for um the
vote and they changed it the s
commission voted and Congress overrode
it and then then that was the day of the
Million Man March which if you look up
that day October 15th
1995 that day and that's that's a
pivotal moment in my life like and and
that day that prison every we took it
over two whole a housing unit was burnt
down to the ground like anything you've
seen in a Hollywood movie half of the
law library and where the the wreck area
was was burnt down and then we were
surrounded by tanks and like armored
vehicles and there was a helicopter
above but simultaneously 12 other
federal prisons simultaneously rioted
now at that prison they took 22 black
eyes and me one white guy and they sent
us to Maran and they they said because
we somehow they they charged us with a
shot which is which is a charge in jail
a 101 and a 00 is murder 101 is uh Riot
it's very dangerous and you can half the
guys that got sent to Maring with me got
an extra 7 to 10 years added on their
sentence and so as a result of the riot
but what happened at that prison there
was something that happened with me with
a um this is the this is the this is
some juicy stuff there was a a duffel
bag I had that someone made for me three
prisons before James
Irving he was in prison for LS too and
so when you have property in prison you
have like a property slip and then then
when you cuz every store doesn't sell
the same thing so when you get
transferred
you you would have your property slipped
so I had this duffel bag
in uh Florence I had it in peakin and
then I had it in uh the there's one in
there's a federal prison in uh downtown
Denver and then I went there and so on
the yard one day this big huge
Lieutenant like when I came into the
prison he said you're not supposed to
have that he's like I know you fak this
property slip and blah blah blah he's
like this looks like it was made out of
a blanket so one day on the
yard he in front of everybody he said I
want that bag you hippie rat and he
threw me to the
ground from nowhere and he grabbed the
bag and I grabbed it back and I called
him I called him a name a Bad Name a
real bad name I just
reacted and the whole yard saw it he
elbowed me one in the face and then you
hit the Deuces right and then everybody
comes running they threw me in the hole
for about six or seven
weeks they took the bag they then you
know you can't react back to a guard
ever like you and I grabbed it like I
just reacted because this guy made it
for me another dead head that I met in
jail so anyway that passes that all
passes over but I started filing these
complaints with the prison system but
then I stopped but one day he told me
he's like if you continue to file these
he's like I will send you to Maran and I
laughed at him because it's like you
could stab a prison guard and not get
sent to Marin it's almost like it could
see what was happening but there was
always a sense of camaraderie on the
yard and I want to digress for one
second when I was in uh Florence
Colorado that was controlled more by the
whites than the blacks but it didn't
matter whites or blacks but one day in
the chow hall we in the chow hall there
was always a white and a black line
which is a dead had never made sense to
me because it was like divide and
conquer
right the Indian came in and he had way
too much to drink and he's got he
started literally he took his Cy like
went at a uh Co a corrections officer
now in the chow hall if you ever do
anything bad you get in really big
trouble because there's four or 600 guys
there's only 15 or 20 guards they're
vulnerable and I witnessed this and so
the the guards started literally just
about beating him to death and then the
two guys from the white side and two
guys from the black side stood up and
they pointed and they're like okay you
send him in you send him in and so in
this midst of this place this prison
this pit of bad and evil this
everybody's doing
time the solidarity of we're going to
send a white guy in and send a black guy
in to help the Indian and then they
started beating those two guys but they
let up on the Indian and they they told
everybody to get down and then they took
them away and so it it seems crude but
like if you see the love in that that
These two factions of people of
different races but I saw many examples
of that and like there there it's not
like it's made out in Hollywood and like
in a Grateful Dead parking lot the love
and the sharing and the the kindness and
and so anyway so now
Maran so we're on the bus we're driving
and they're not telling us where we're
going and everybody's trying to guess
where they're going and I all of a
sudden this thing of horror comes over
me this is after the place is burnt down
this is after everybody's
charged I said holy [__] we're going to
Marion and everybody looked at me
they're like there was silence you could
hear a pin drop and there was this big
mirror on the prison bus and the guy
looks up like this and he just smirks
when we got to Maran it's a long ride
there was a regiment of the Ninja
Turtles they're dressed with everything
the shock plates the things the big
looks like you know
Skywalker and they're lined up like 14
deep and 10 wide and the guy's got a
camera now I was only on Talladega yard
for maybe five or six months in two or
three months I was in the hole because
the duffel bag incident we got off the
bus they beat up everybody but maybe
three people and me like beat them in
front of everybody one at a time right
to the bad beat him bad and they plan
this whole entire thing out from the
beginning and so then we they check you
in they bring you in you see a doctor
this like anytime you go to a prison you
see a doctor you
see uh the counselor do you have any
diseases you fill out all the paperwork
you change your clothes you shower so
then we're all in a holding
cell this is maybe 3 hours later the
guys that got the brutal brutalist
beatings are bandaged
up I mean I'm telling the story if
someone told me this story I don't even
think I'd believe it and so now once
you're in
Maran it's a super max prison so you
cannot be next to a guard without being
handcuffed and Shackled and the whole
check-in process and all that the way
it's set up you don't so we're in the
holding cell and if you can imagine a
big rectangular room and then in the the
corner of the room there's a little tiny
box and so you go into that box you get
handcuffed and
Shackled but outside of the box they're
reaching in and then they take you to
your cell but what they do is they say
Blazer come on you cuffing up first and
there's three guys they didn't touch
they were big and they didn't know me
and so they cuffed me and handcuffed me
behind my back and then they they open
up the door to go back in the cage and I
I'm pretty naive and I just thought oh
okay and I go back into the cage and I'm
like oh my God I'm in here right and
then all of a sudden the biggest dude in
the cell he starts bitching at the guard
[__] we're not going to touch
him man it's us against you and like
they started like like all as one like
[__] you [__] you [__] you [__] you and
they left me in there for about 15
minutes then they started cuffing
everybody up but like that's that was my
introduction to Marion but I'll also say
this when they brought me to my cell I
was [__] grateful that I had a cell
with nobody in it I mean I was prison
but like I and they had bars so it was a
little bit of easier
time so but does that answer your
question about Marian yeah I think it
does and so you got out and what have
you done since you got out um I got out
on September
7th
1997 yes because I okay I filed four
appeals one went to the Supreme Court
one went to the appell court I got
action on two I lost two the one that
went to the Supreme Court was held in a
bance so if there's an appeal that has a
like kind issue exactly you can attach
yours and the court will say before they
read the make the decision they'll make
a decision on we're going to hold yours
in a bance which means essentially it's
the same thing and so I got 90
months reduced 20 and then 50 so I
served 60 one months and then when I got
out um okay I'll tell you a story I got
out and I worked at the Bradley Center
which is now the fiser Forum they
wrecked it but you know doing catering
and then I got a job washing dishes and
then one day when I was going to work
the house across the street from me I
saw just just as I was leaving like dea
FBI like all these cars pulled up and
I'm like oh my God I'm like thinking
wait a second I'm not doing anything but
they they went to this house and then I
stood there and then within maybe like
three minutes the guy comes out with a
big huge bag of
cocaine and I'm like they're going to
confiscate that
house because you in jail it doesn't
matter who you are there's law libraries
there was a case uh US versus bounds
which defined right to council it was in
the' 70s
and right to councel if you're in prison
means Law Library so the law libraries
are pretty well stocked and so even a
dumb
prisoner you get to learn a lot about
law and um I went down to the marshals
the next day and I said I want to make
an unsolicited bid on this house I know
you're going to confiscate it and back
then they had an Arcane rule where if
you were if you came to
them with an unsolicited bid you got
first dibs on the house so 18 months
later I got that house and I restored it
and sold it and that started my I mean I
guess I'm an artist and my my late the
last
20 something years I mean 08 I hit a big
bump and I had to start over from where
do you live now I'm kind of just all
over but I'm I'm staying in Milwaukee
because I had some health tests done but
I I'm looking to go somewhere else I'm
not sure I was traveling all year I sold
my last house looking back at your life
do you have regrets or do you have
things you wish you had done differently
uh
um the regrets are things that I wish
I'd done differently I don't it's
hindsight is always 2020 looking through
the rear view mirror and the one thing
that I've I've one thing I don't know if
I have regrets but one thing that I've
learned is that to
know my
smartest attribute today could be
knowing how dumb I am and like where's
my circle of competence and staying
within that and then um a
regret that's a tough one I remember the
last the my mother was very sick I wear
this in honor of my parents this is
their ring and um a couple days before
she died we were spending a lot of time
with her and we know that she was going
to pass and oh my God this is going to
be on here um but she wanted to stay
with me that night stay with her that
night now she didn't die that night and
I but I think the what I believe is she
was ready to go and she wanted to go
that night and she wanted me to be with
her and she held on for three more days
but we were with her she was completely
conscious so that doesn't haunt me but
it really makes me think about you know
what what is really valuable and where
am I in a rush to get to like the the
past and the future is has has never
been and never will be the only thing
that's real is right here right now it's
this what matters and in that moment she
wanted me to be with her now had she
died that night I I I don't know if I
would be here today but she didn't but
so that is an almost regret if that's if
that's
one and Joel what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life the most important so far a one
that most is a big word but absolutely
to not have resentments they're like
poison like that is and oh can I share
another story about where I learned that
sure in Mary
uh I won't turn it into a big story but
there was a situation where I had
already told you about Tommy silver
Sting If that if that makes it in here
but one day I didn't get my
wreck and I blurted some stuff out and I
used his name and then they brought
every prison guard in front of my cell
and then my mom came to visit me on New
Year's Eve and they just beat the [__]
out of me coming out of there and it's
the only time that anything physical
ever happened to me in prison but I kind
of had it coming and it g garnered some
more respect and that half the guys I
three quarters of the guys I got off the
bus with got their asses whipped but
anyway a couple months later I was in
the hole and I realized that I had a
very good shot at maybe winning my
appeal and going home like soon and I
don't know how it came over me I wasn't
in AA I wasn't religious I it had to be
from the LSD and the halloa Jens but
these two cops came in in the hole and
they just were like talking about having
sex with their wives and trying to to
get us all hot and bothered and when
they left me and ghetto laughed at each
other but I had this incredible sense of
empathy and sympathy for them and then
somehow something came to me I'm just
part of the hole if anybody asks me what
I am I'm part of the hole I don't
restore houses I want to be part of the
hole and I said I have to pray for these
people I cannot leave here with
resentments against these prison guards
or I'll be in life I'll have a life term
of prison I that'll be a mental prison I
will never get out of
and so don't get me wrong I'm human I'll
I'll get a resentment and I got to pray
for someone for two weeks but that was
my first lesson in this pit of
wickedness and I'm not somebody special
because everybody on that role none of
them got mad at the cops to varying
degrees so I'd say the biggest lesson
like that's a big one that's a big
lesson and um the other thing is I I am
so sensitive to the world I'm such a
recluse and such a uh
introvert I really am but that I just
and I don't want to pant myself on the
back but I'm so glad I didn't tell like
I would have been [__] up man I
probably would have ODed and gotten
addicted to fentanyl or Coke or
something really bad I mean I mean had
my issues with Coke but is there
anything else no that's good that's
great Joel thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you Mark you had an
interesting life how long was that 48
minutes 48 minutes
wow